It's like we're building our
society from an etch a sketch.
We were given a solid foundation in
a warning of what dangers to avoid.
At some point, someone came in long,
Andrew Dix all over our etch a sketch.
We are afraid to lose our work for
had such potential, but it is dead.
It has been hijacked and
we need to shake it clean.
George Orwell's stated that the best
books are the ones that tell you what you
already know.
1984 will tell you what you already know,
that there was something
very wrong with our culture.
Okay. War is peace. Freedom is slavery.
Ignorance is strength.
These were the three slogans of ink sock.
The totalitarian party,
which controlled the superstate of Oceania
in George Orwell's dystopian novel,
1984 these slogans were precisely chosen
to create cognitive dissonance in the
citizen's minds. Each slogan uses words
directly contradictory to one another.
It was a concept known by party members
as double think to hold paradox school
views of reality.
Simultaneously. In your mind,
you were asked to completely disregard
your own perception and be completely
dependent on the state's
definition of reality.
If the party needed you to believe that
two plus two equals five do you have to
find some way to resolve the fact that
you know that equals four it is not just
enough to say the words.
The party was very sophisticated in
observing when you were faking it.
You needed to actually believe when a
party member holds up two and two fingers,
you are truly seeing five.
Furthermore,
if the party puts you in a situation
where two plus two must equal for for the
sake of science and practicality,
you must find a way to resolve these
two paradigms as the party soffit.
Sometimes the answer was five,
sometimes it was three and sometimes
it was all of them at once.
The party specifically denies this
such a thing as the truth even exists.
The objective truth is whatever suits
their needs at the time in soc controls
all records, all memories of past events,
and they control your entire reality.
There would be no loyalty
but loyalty to the party.
There'd be no love but
love for big brother.
The validity of the human experience and
the very existence of external reality
itself was denied by their philosophy.
The greatest of all Harris's was common
sense and the most terrifying thing
about this proposition was not that they
would kill you for thinking otherwise.
What was truly terrifying was what if
they were rights first common sense,
truth like two plus two equals four or
the existence of gravity or that the past
is
if these ideas exist only in the
mind and the mind is controllable,
what happens then?
The truth becomes whatever
those empower want it to be.
The way this manifested in Orwell's
nightmarish reality was this.
If someone you knew disappeared,
they were no longer a person
and in fact never existed,
any record of them was wiped out.
Any memory you had of them was false.
It was your imagination and speaking
about them could lead to your own sudden
disappearance.
The State of Oceania had two main rivals,
Eurasia and East Asia.
Whoever they were at war with in this
moment was who they had always been at war
with. Even if you had a memory of being
at war with East Asia four weeks ago.
Right now we are at war with your ratio
and had always been at war with your
ratio, any piece of news that had
ever said otherwise, it was altered.
Anyone who spoke to the
contrary, was it criminal? Okay.
When the planes hit the two towers on
nine 11 it was very clear what we needed
to do. We needed to find who was
responsible and crushed them.
Osama bin Laden was responsible. Osama
bin Laden had always been responsible.
This led to a war in Afghanistan.
Afghanistan had always been behind
the terror attacks on nine 11
so as the war with Iraq waged on,
we knew they had always had
weapons of mass destruction.
We all knew we had to rid this evil
totalitarian country of these weapons.
So this is the war in
Afghanistan continued. We came
to the realization to Iraq.
Never had weapons of mass destruction,
but this was okay.
That had never been the reason for
going to war in the first place.
What I rack really needed.
Okay.
Was the regime change?
Whoever controls the present controls
the past and thus controls the future.
Those who control our history books are
able to control our perception of the
past.
Like most kids in America,
I was taught that no matter
which war we were fighting,
the United States was on the sight of God,
truth and justice.
This,
but history proves to be much more
complex than our linear way of learning in
schools allows us to understand,
okay,
every historical subject and we learned
gets condensed into a narrow lens,
usually portraying and imposing on us
a belief of American exceptionalism.
God's chosen people who've been burdened
with the task of enlightening other
cultures of their primitive ways.
And the 241 years since 1776 the United
States has been engaged in some type of
war for 224 of them wore in reality,
by definition should be something
that inevitably comes to an end.
There was a clear enemy. We fight.
We go until there was a clear victor,
then the war ends. The wars between
Oceania, East Asia, Eurasia.
We're not battles over resources.
War was enacted to keep a labor force
within its own boundaries in Orwell's
novel by becoming continuous
war has ceased to exist.
Each willpower stockpiles atomic
weapons and points the met each other,
planning and plotting for
the right moment. Of course,
this moment never comes and the leaders
of instock never want it to come.
None of the three powers ever attempt
any maneuver which involves the risk of
serious defeat in this way,
big battles and wars are being fought.
It could be true,
it could be a lie. The citizens
of Oceania have no way of knowing.
The real truth is that each superstate
is nearly identical to one another with
only slight differences in
way of life in ideology.
This is why each superstate does
not want to conquer one another.
If you were to conquer a new territory,
what would you do with its people?
You can either have a mass genocide or
you can assimilate these people into your
own society.
That would be almost unthinkable if the
residents of Oceania actually mingled
with the enemy that had
been propped up for so long.
Soon they would come to realize that
they are more similar to themselves then
they could have ever
imagined in Orwell's reality.
War is waged by each ruling
class against its own subjects.
The object of war is not to take
your perfect conquest of territory,
but to keep the very
structure of society in tact.
A hierarchical society requires
a certain way of thinking,
particularly a feeling of scarcity and
lack that's drink too far from the herd
will result in death.
When war becomes literally continuous,
there was no such thing
as military necessity.
The war becomes merely an imposter.
It becomes like a battle between two
animals live set their horns at such an
angle that they are incapable
of hurting one another.
This is not to say that many people
won't die. Certainly they will,
but the foundation of these superpowers,
the way of life is never
endanger for even an instinct.
Though it is just an act.
It is not meaningless.
War eats up the surplus
of consumable goods,
and it helps to preserve the mental
atmosphere that a hierarchical society
requires.
A state of perpetual war has become
nearly identical to a state of perpetual
peace
throughout recorded time. There has always
been three types of people. The high,
the middle, and the low. They
have been subdivided many
ways, born countless names,
but the central structure of
society has never changed.
Even after enormous upheaval is the same
pattern has always reasserted itself,
just as a gyroscope will
always return to equilibrium.
The aims of these three groups
are entirely irreconcilable.
The aim of the high is
to remain where they are.
The aim of the middle is to overthrow in
change places with the high and the aim
of the low if they have an aim is to
abolish all distinctions and create a
society where all are equal.
Thus a struggle which maintains the
same basic outline recurs over and over
again.
The need for a hierarchical society has
always been the doctrine of the high.
The high had promised you safety and
security and all the riches available in
the next slide.
All it estin return was everything.
All of the riches in this world.
There are four ways in which your
ruling class can fall from power.
Either it is conquer from without. It
governs so poorly that the masses revolts.
It allows us strong discontented
middle group to develop or a loses self
confidence and willingness to govern a
ruling class which could guard against
all of these would remain
in power permanently.
The high realizing history was a cyclical
process and that the middle and low
would always try to usurp their status,
chose to find a way to maintain
their position permanently.
This new group of high was more conscious
of what they were doing and more
focused on crushing their opposition.
This new group of high realized the
only way to keep an oligarchy intact was
through collectivism.
A society needed to exist with the greater
good of the group always had priority
over the individual.
One of the main mistakes these groups
have made in the past was the forming of
an aristocracy. The privileged few
flaunted themselves. They had slaves.
They made it very clear that they
were the high and we were the low.
Once the high had an
overwhelming amount of resources,
the middle would inevitably enlist the
low to overthrow the high usually to a
violent in the key to success needed
to be secrecy and shadowed intentions,
the new oligarchy, the one
that can actually maintain
their status as the high.
We'll have to learn how
to hide their true aims
today. The high are no longer people.
They are corporations and institutions,
institutions which are too big to fail.
They become something like the
Federal Reserve, the very name,
a brilliant act of double thing.
It would suggest to an observer that they
are beholden to the federal government
and that they hold the reserve
of our currency. In reality,
they are not a part of the federal
government nor do they hold any reserves.
They are nameless,
faceless shape shifting entity with no
loyalty or ties to anyone or anything.
Nathan Rothschild once said,
give me control of a nation's wealth
and I care not who makes its laws.
Once you have gained complete
control of a nation's wealth,
you can then plaster the face of a big
brother who is always watching you on to
every TV,
every street corner,
and didn't every home while the
high remains truly anonymous.
Okay?
Through collectivism,
the hire able to keep up the illusion
that we've not been in sleep,
people are not productive when
we realize our enslavement,
our human spirit compels us to break
free of our masters. And furthermore,
when you knowingly in slave someone,
you don't want to educate them for them,
they use it to turn against you.
So you are only able to take advantage
of the muscle of your human farm and not
the most valuable asset.
Their minds
give them the illusion of freedom.
Let them choose their job,
where they want to vacation and how
they want to spend their free time.
They will choose a job that is safe and
secure though they have the ability to
go as far and for as long as they want.
They will vacation where countless
people have gone before and will always
return home when they are told and
inevitably almost all our various forms of
entertainment will merely
become a way to numb our senses,
give them the illusion of choice
and they will imprison themselves.
Thus,
freedom is slavery.
In 1984 the ink sock party was in the
middle of implementing a new type of
language called quite
creatively new speak.
It would take time,
however,
to replace all the unnecessary old speak
words with the more useful, efficient,
new speak words, words that meant
the same thing were thrown away.
Words like fantastic,
ecstatic and amazing exist when they
could be covered by the word good.
If something was better,
it would be double good.
Something bad was simply an good language
was simplified as much as possible.
The goal of the party was to have any
idea divergent from the ink sock doctrine.
Literally unthinkable. All ambiguity
and shades of meaning were purged out.
Newspeak was designed to limit the range
of thought and there would be no room
for philosophical discussion.
In a world like this.
How could one fight back when the
thoughts and words that have a revolution
couldn't even be thought or spoken?
Look at this example from Orwell's
article politics in the English language,
which shows the path modern
day English is heading down.
He takes a verse from ecclesiastics and
translates it into a more modern day
English type of writing.
I returned and saw under the sun that
the race is not to the swift nor the
battle to the strong,
neither yet bread to the wise nor yet
riches to men of understanding nor yet
favor to men of skill,
but time and chance happiness to them all.
Let's look at how the same sentence
would be written in a more modern day
English type of writing.
Objective considerations of contemporary
phenomena compelled the conclusion that
success or failure in competitive
activities exhibits no tendency to be
commiserate with the neat capacity,
but then a considerable element of the
unpredictable must invariably be taken
into account.
The first sentence contains 49 words,
but only 60 syllables and all
its words those of everyday life.
The second contains 38
words of 90 syllables.
Every form of imagery and
concrete illustration has
dissolved into these vague
phrases and just by its 90 syllables,
it gives us only a shortened version of
the meaning contained in the first yet
without a doubt,
it is the second kind of sentence which
is gaining ground in modern English.
This type of writing is youthful.
If one wants to hide their meaning and in
political language, this is everything.
For those who claimed a power must always
portray their reasons for doing so as
noble, they did it for
truth, God and justice.
This is rarely true.
Power has always been acquired for power's
sake or will realize this and realize
that this trick is often masked by
language leaders, politicians and media,
often new soft language
to mask a brutal reality.
British rule in India, the Russian
purges and deportations under stolen,
the dropping of the atom bombs
in Japan can be defended,
but only by arguments which are too brutal
for most people to face and which do
not align with the professed
aims of the political parties.
Euphemism is what makes up the majority
of our political language deficits.
Villages are bomb from the
air, the inhabitance driven
out into the countryside,
the cattle machine gun in the home set
on fire. This was called pacification.
Such phrase,
knowledge is needed if one wants to
name things without calling a mental
pictures of them.
This is the trick.
You youth a nice name
for a horrific thing.
Political writing and speech is
often a defense of the indefensible.
Very often the words chosen directly
contradict the ideas they represent.
This kind of speech is
not hard to recognize,
so the speaker is dependent on
one key fact about human nature,
and that is the individual's
desire to deceive himself.
We all have a story,
a sort of internal narrative which shapes
our identity and molds our perception.
In 1984 the narrative was that big
brother was omnipotent and the party was
infallible,
but because big brother was not omnipotent
and the party was not infallible,
there was need for an unwavering moment
to moment flexibility in the treatment
of facts.
One needed control over their own mental
processes as complete as that of a
contortionist over his body in new speak.
This is called double think.
Double think less is the very heart of
ink sock way of life since the essential
act of the party is to use conscious
deception while retaining the firmness of
purpose that goes with complete honesty,
to tell deliberate lies while
genuinely believing in it.
This brings up the question, why must
reality be distorted in this manner?
Okay.
Why must the narrative pervade every
layer of the societal structure?
It is important to realize that
power is in the collective alone.
Every human being will fail because every
human being is doomed to die,
but if he can make complete utter
submission, if he can escape his identity,
if you can immerse himself into
the parties that he is the party,
then he is all powerful and a mortal.
You see then why you must never lose
faith in the infallibility of your country
or political group.
These things make up the foundation of
how you interpret the world and if they
collapse, your entire structure
of beliefs will collapse with it.
This is why above all the story,
the narrative and the mythologies must
remain intact and why you will follow
your culture down whatever
path it leads you.
We tend to think of an oppressive regime
is containing two categories of people.
The oppressive rule in class and the
innocent people who are being oppressed.
We think of tyranny is something
which comes from the top down,
but a system like that
simply would not function.
Regimes like that have stolen or Hitler
required the willing participation of a
mass amount of people.
This is not fit very well with
our perception of what happened.
It is much easier to look at history
as a case of black and white,
right and wrong or good and evil,
and each of us would like to believe
if we were put in that situation,
we would take the side of good.
If only it were that simple.
If only there were some
unmistakable mark of evil,
we could simply separate
the good from the bad.
But the line between good and evil does
not pass through political parties nor
states nor social classes,
but right through every human heart.
This runs absolutely counter to
what we would like to believe.
We lack our villains out in the open
where they can be easily identified,
but it was not good men or bad men who
were behind the horrors of Auschwitz and
Soviet Russia.
It was ordinary men,
people just like you and me.
To truly understand Nazi Germany or
Stalin's Russia is to understand the
ordinary people,
meaning you and I.
If we were put in that situation, we
would have done what ordinary people did.
What every totalitarian state had in
common was the layer of deceit and bed
within its culture and within his language
and a willingness of the individual
to accept an act out in lists lies.
This is what Orwell so eloquently brought
to light and politics in the English
language.
Speaking in an imprecise man,
or at least the groundwork for society
built unconscious deception and it starts
at the level of the individual.
We can not lay responsibility
at the feet of another.
For the enemy is not some
dictator in a far away land.
When we realize the enemy
lies within our own hearts,
suddenly one becomes too.
We have found the enemy and he is us.
Okay.